Aurélie notre avant-dernière candidate
qui a beaucoup de mal à descendre je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'a alors tout le monde que ça
va
elle va faire une bise à
[Musique]
l'autre et pourquoi tu as embrasser le
petit garçon parce que j'ai
envie est-ce
que
[Musique]
fait la
T Enie de faire
vasy tu viens
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu dis
là
voilà et toi qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
quand tu s grandeah
[Musique]
oui qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
fasse bouilles
d'oreilles il a des bouilles
d'oreilles
alors quelle chanson tu nous chantes là
allez donnez-moi la première note vas-y
alle bah oui toutes les fesond alors
comment elle s'appelle la chanson Riri
Fifi Loulou et tu as compris ou quoi oui
bien s il courra partout pour rattraper
les rapou qui VOA
toujours pou il font du sport et T
efforts pour des casseur junior